you know it was his side you know aside
from Will Smith and actually in some
ways the avian superior will in certain
ways will suffered a huge movie star
maybe one of the biggest in the world
Queen Latifah is kind of like this huge
cultural figure whoo-hoo it's big in
movies but she can sell cosmetics she's
had talk shows uh she she kind of
represents more than wills does like
most of this says will is like a vacuum
in which you read in what you will but
you know he doesn't give you a lot of
personal detail it's really this package
Latifah seems to represent two women a
sense of empowerment and strength that's
beyond her just her actual cultural
products and so getting her to do this
film was humongous his reason to film
exists quite honestly all certainly
exists on the scale I don't know that I
mean I probably would've got it made
somewhere but would have HBO have you
know from about it the way they did they
did a fantastic job we played Sundance
in the whole shebang and I think it's
because of her because she represents a
certain strength and a certain kind of
integrity that somehow even if I she
does stupid comedies it doesn't stop
people from feeling lay about her she's
a remarkable figure and that she's loved
by kids she's really respected and loved
by women and adults she's affected by
men uh it's it's really a unique place
she's carved out for ourselves and she's
a lovely person I mean I didn't sound
like you know the usual cliche but she's
incredibly easy to work where she's a
lot of fun she likes to tell lots and
lots of jokes given her brother she
would just do comedy's all the time
probably she's got a really strong
spirit and it radiates through right
through the screen so I mean she was
that she was a dream to work with and
she was very clear about why she did
that my film and what it was about and
not to make this is not going to be
bringing down a house this is definitely
another space and I and while we're in
this space artistically this is what
we're doing as soon as the camp will you
say cut I can go and around and
mess around but this is where i am and i
think that that was one thing i really
loved about her she didn't try and pose
any other aesthetics on to hollywood
aesthetics or anything like that she
bought into this material and she was
committed to a certain kind of reality
for the material